wo 907 auftaucht geraten die berge
schnell einmal so katastrophengebiet
der langjährige experte für solche
action schauplätze heißt stefan zürcher
der waldschneise kilometer lang 20 meter
breit und ich glaube nicht dass mit
offiziellem anderen machen
20 grund in österreich natürlich
vielfältige woche hier in einem projekt
ungefährlichkeit so millionen euro
hierzulande bekommt ein bund keine
filmförderung
trotzdem konnte stefan zürcher die
meisten berg abenteuer von 007 bisher in
der schweiz ansiedeln wie hier zum
beispiel am dalli stocker
das daher stärker um die teile storkow
summe goldeneye film oder der
eröffnungsszene heck macht mehrheit der
rampe und der stuhl für 100 meter mit 7
ganz neue che was der film selber mal
die zähne breit und es ist sehr
schwierig sie das timing zur
vorbereitung zehntelsekunden vor der
eiger nordwand heimat der flieger im
sturzflug trägt
sie stiegen nach erfahrung der green
screen studio
geht es um imposante filmkulissen sind
die schweizer alpen nicht zu toppen
auf den bergen und am horizont und das
ist einfach ist es vor der bergung vor
der berglandschaft
die schweiz bietet noch mehr kulissen
potenzial die besetzung der nazi
hochburg berchtesgaden durch us truppen
hat stefan zürcher in interlaken
angesiedelt obwohl band of brothers die
historische krieg serie von steven
spielberg und tom hanks produziert in
deutschland und österreich spielt
wir fahren morgen früh nach österreich
weiter aber wir müssen für die die nach
uns hierher kommt nichts übrig lassen
nach österreich
in wahrheit gelangt die us-armee und
brienzersee stefan zürcher machte es
möglich
das aktuelle wahnsinnigen mit den 400
statisten morgen für musik redet wird
als soldat und nach einer melodie ganze
fahrzeuge über 40 fahrzeuge kamen teil
von dem was man alle position bringen
mit einer ganzen stadt ist seine und das
natürlich diese rufe logistik stefan
zurück hat jahrzehntelange erfahrung als
bühnenbildner für alpine filmszenen
jeder schauplatz weckt anekdotische
erinnerungen was sie da die szene mit
bleibt die frage warum das eigentlich in
der schweiz gedreht wurde und nicht an
den originalschauplätzen eine große und
das atelier spielberg und dem tom hensel
des abfall und umsetzen
die politik das geld die landschaft das
know how es gibt viele faktoren die mit
spielen bei der wahl von film drehorten
hauptsache die illusion funktioniert